it's so good to see you guys hope you're
both doing well big congratulations on
the move be here because it's it's
colorful and wacky and fun thank you so
you both worked with Chris before so
what is it about him as an animated
movie actors director that made you guys
say we got to get back to working with
him on something new uh well I did
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs 2 with
him and that was my first big animated
movie and he just made it you know it's
weird because you don't know what's
happening you know and you always have
to have someone explain to you the
context of what's going on I mean you
know it's like green screen times 1000
where Li look there's people here and
there's the sky there and you're looking
at this plane and yeah and it's just it
could get really really confusing very
very quickly and Chris does the most
amazing time he's literally looks at you
and and you I felt like a five-year-old
listening to a story every time I went
into the studio he's like and now Terry
you see these people and they're coming
and it can be is going all over and
you're like just keep talking this keep
talking and then you're right into what
you need to do and I knew that working
with Chris him being a writer a director
a true creative that it was a you know I
had to do it again and it is I can't be
prouder of what we came up I feel
exactly the same way what Terry just
said I think there's also a great trust
in Chris he is someone he's your main
collaborator in the room when you are
making these animated movies and so to
have someone who is he has the essence
of the child who'd be watching it whilst
you're making it and so I feel he
transmits that joy and the clarity of
the story to you of what needs to come
off and it's just I always look forward
to every single session we were gonna
have that I could spend time with him
and he and take some of his infectious
joy and personality for the project
working on Genki tell me about figuring
out the right tone for your character
with him because it can be a very fine
line between satirical and making her
come across as too mean and the fact
that you guys can still make mother and
father very funny characters was very
impressive to me so what was the process
like of nailing that I think Chris and
and everyone involved was very sensitive
to that to sort of riding that fine line
I happen to be working opposite the
genius Martin Short so I sort of feel
like I bowed to his lead through most of
the the recording sessions and Chris was
very good about knowing what were the
moments we could sort of highlight to
make them more humorous and their
cartoony nature versus just being sort
of neglectful parents it works really
well I think that was one of the most
impressive parts of the film but Terry
I've got to say that melon off was an
easy favorite for me because my
grandfather was a candy man so whenever
I saw a character the taps into that
industry it always hits home what was it
like seeing him in his final version for
the very first time what was the biggest
difference between what you read on the
page and what he turned out to be well
oh man um first of all the animation is
incredible I actually was going to be an
animator when I first got to Hollywood I
mean I was an artist the whole thing I
had my portfolio in at Disney and the
whole deal and then I ended up being an
actor so I have so much respect for what
these guys do and you know to see Mellon
all actually look like me really studied
and saw how I act my behavior my whole
thing and you know for me it was just
such a sadist behind peace because you
know you do this voice your hope it
comes across and I could not be happier
it was it's kind of like I imagined me
on my cheat day like every day
equal to this movie should be a
live-action sequel for melon off and
nanny and you and Maya should just stay
in the roles what's so great is that
everyone on this cast those people that
always want to work with with James with
Martin Short and you know I work with
Maya
we did it iakh recei years ago and it
was just a pleasure to get back and you
know it's really really one thing I also
want to talk about just at the tone of
this movie I think is what the country
needs right now because it's not one of
those you know just happy-go-lucky it's
got a lot of serious things that you
know usually would never be attempted in
a kid's movie and I thought man this is
brave this is really groundbreaking and
how it came out I thought was just
perfect for the tone of the country and
what we're going through right now thank
you guys so much for your time today I
appreciate it and again congratulations
on the movie I think exactly what you
said is true and Netflix is just
crushing it the animation Department for
that reason right now so thank you guys
I hope you enjoy your virtual drum kit